from arid desert to rugged mountains
this is the us-mexico border that the
president has promised to protect a vow
that led to the shutdown of government
and could well do again whether you call
it offensive barrier steel flats or a
wall this is what the Trump
administration has built so far the
structure the President believes is
worth fighting so hard for this section
covers 20 miles of land in New Mexico
but not one new mile of the nearly two
thousand along the border has yet been
built on or funded by Congress what
you're seeing is a replacement and it
sits right next to something far smaller
designed to stop vehicles not those on
foot there is nothing uniform about this
land and no singular solution
in El Paso this is what crowd control
looks like a military-style rehearsal
for a potential influx of immigrants
amused Mexicans watching on through the
gaps they say they're preparing for the
next migrant caravan that could pass
through here it's been a hotspot for
illegal crossings in the past and they
say this show of force is what they need
to respond to it
and walls the agents maintain make their
work what effect do barriers have or
other resources infrastructure that we
have what effect does that have well
it's fantastic in the sense that we
identify where our threats are where our
gaps and coverage are and this is a tool
that allows us to enhance our ability to
respond or to deter the potential
crossers of either people or goods and
so the impact is in this area where we
used to have right here in this area
we're used to have 30 40 50 people run
across at any given point in time almost
nightly now because of the type of
barrier that we have if we do have
crossings we're talking about two or
three people but for El Paso's
Republican mayor it is a system more
than a structure that needs to be looked
at do you think a big wall will make a
difference I'm a former CEO so I'm into
results it's hard to say right now I
think we're dealing with too much Punda
tree and talking heads and opinions and
possibly not listening to the people on
the ground closely enough migrants and
illegal immigrants who are you know not
criminals who are working but using
false Social Security numbers and things
like that my position is venom from a
criminal standpoint and give them green
cards I mean the eggs been broken
there's nothing else we can do 800 miles
along the border the Rio Grande River
provides a natural barrier
an area rich in biodiversity and home to
a 100 Acre Wildlife Sanctuary but this
month
construction begins on the first
brand-new stretch of wall that will cut
straight through it funded by money
already approved before the shutdown we
have many species of birds mammals
insects here at the Rio Grande Valley
that you will not find anywhere else
United States what impact do you think
the wall will have here there's gonna be
the destruction of habitat when the
bulldozers come in to clear the land for
the border wall some of the wildlife
will be killed instantly when they're
run over by the machines other will die
slowly nanometre Church in Mission is
also in the crosshairs it's dawn
services punctuated by country music and
spirited servants that's important for
us as we clash with the powers that be
don't it'll make you me nosotros somos
de las casas con fear all the wall could
very soon force this century-old Chapel
into a no-man's land between Mexico and
Ameri
and the man they call the cowboy priest
is now locked in a legal fight
you can see where people have tried to
make it over
father Snipes believes they've been
unfairly demonized the description of
this is a crisis zone with murderers and
rapists coming across is that's a real
shame that's just that's sick you know
people do come across and there are
murders but if you look at our society
like our just our town or any town the
most hardened criminals we've got are
people that have papers the people in
our town who don't have papers are
mostly our best neighbors the government
is seizing land under the policy of
eminent domain it could split homes
businesses and communities that many
just aren't ready to give up
cordelia Lynch Sky News on the US Mexico
border